[Music]
hello everybody i am pete holmes and
welcome to the conan after hours stand
up series presented by pepsi next where
we showcase some of the show's favorite
comedians tonight's performer is a host
of the professor blastoff podcast please
welcome our good friend tig notaro
everybody
oh so um
i live here in los angeles and i went to
this party with this friend of mine pam
and when we were leaving the party
she said to me
do you know who that was standing by the
door
i said no
she said that was taylor dane
i was like oh my gosh
i love taylor dane
do you know who taylor dana
she was a pop singer in the late 80s
early 90s
she's saying love will lead you back
she's saying tell it to my heart
do you want me to sing it for you
[Applause]
i am singing it
[Applause]
does that sound familiar at
all anyway i love taylor dane
and not ironically
i love her
so i went back into the party
and i went up to her and i said excuse
me
i'm sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
i love your voice
and she just turned and said
yeah i don't do that anymore
it felt horrible i looked over and this
other friend of mine was doubled over
laughing at me
she said yeah you just got dissed by
taylor dane
it felt horrible so i left the party
then like nine months passed
i happen to be out to eat with that same
friend of mine pam
there's a party of ten seated right
behind us
you guys are not gonna believe who is
sitting there
any guesses
[Applause]
just think about the story i've been
telling
yeah it was taylor dane
that's exactly who it was
my friend pam was like oh my gosh you
have to say something to her
i said
no question
i didn't i couldn't figure out what i
could say to her
then i realized the best thing that i
could say to taylor dane would be the
exact
same sentence
that i said to her the first time
so i turned around
i interrupted her entire dinner
i said excuse me i'm sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
i love your voice
and she said
my speaking voice
and i said
yes
oh my gosh
i'm completely blanking on what happens
next
in this story that i've told a few times
so taylor dane says
wait guys i'm blinking
this is hilarious you guys are thinking
this is a joke but it's not
you're like wow you've already built an
awkward situation
so certainly this is part of the bit
it's not
this is me taping something
and realizing i'm forgetting my story
then you guys are like oh my gosh this
is horrifying
then the people from conan are watching
this on monitors going this is really
horrifying
we've paid you and we took a
we had a limo take you here
to forget your story
i was out to eat with that same friend
of mine pam
what's funny is this really happened to
me
i'm not making this up
they told me go as long as you need to
tell this story this is way longer than
they were expecting
yeah this is awkward i know
i don't know what to do
woo was right
so i turned around
and i interrupted her entire dinner
i said excuse me
sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
i love your voice
and she said
my speaking voice
and i said
yes
what i didn't realize at the time was
that taylor dane was no longer pursuing
a singing career she was pursuing an
acting career
which i guess is why she was no longer
accepting compliments
and her singing voice
there's more
than like a year passed
and i was at my riding partner
kyle's house
my phone rang
it was sarah silverman
and at the time sarah was dating jimmy
kimmel and sarah called and said
guess
who's promoting a new cd
on jimmy's show tomorrow night
you guys will not believe who it was
yeah it was tailored in
sarah said i want you to come down
to jimmy's show tomorrow night
and i want you to say
those exact
same words
you said the other times
and i said
no question
but i didn't end up having to go
to jimmy's show the next night
because that same day
that
yeah hear me out
that same day that sarah called me at
kyle's house kyle and i took a lunch
break we ordered lunch to be picked up
we walked across the street
to the strip mall where the restaurant
was
kyle was walking in front of me
i was walking behind him
we walked up to the restaurant he opened
the door
he looked at this table
then he looked back at me
then he looked back at the table and i
was like
yeah yeah of course she's here
then kyle and i walked over to the
counter where our food was waiting for
us and kyle was just pacing back and
forth about to have a stroke
and i was like what is your problem and
he said nothing i'm just really
uncomfortable right now
i said why
he said because i know it's about to
happen
and i said yeah
and i can't wait to do it
i said this has nothing to do with you
i said this is between me
and taylor dame
i said but what i do need you to do
when i go over and interrupt her lunch
i want you to take my cell phone and
just point it in the general vicinity
and videotape me talking to taylor dane
just so i finally have proof
and kyle said okay
so i walked up to taylor dane's table
i said
excuse me
sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
i love your voice
and she said
thank you
and i was like
that was weird
but the best part was when kyle and i
went back and looked at that video
footage you didn't hear me talking to
taylor dane
you just saw me go
and then over that video footage you
hear kyle
in an imaginary conversation
going
oh hey
hey man what's going on
i'm having lunch
at the chicken cafe
no at the pizza cafe at the california
chicken kitchen pizza kitchen cafe
so the person that kyle made up in that
conversation was the world's most
difficult human being
that will not let the easy stuff slide
the person on the other end of that call
is going whoa whoa whoa back up dude
where are you having lunch
at the chicken what cafe
nah man i've never heard of that place
this conversation is going no further
until you make it clear to me where
exactly you're having lunch right now
it was all up to kyle he could have made
up anybody he wanted in that
conversation could have made up a nice
friend
he actually didn't have to be saying
anything at all
i actually feel confident that i'm the
reason that taylor dane ended up putting
out another record
because you know she called her manager
i was like my fans miss me
they love me
i mean sure they're a bunch of he she
looking robots
excuse me
i'm sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
i love your voice excuse me
i'm sorry to bother you
but i just have to tell you
excuse me
people are always like there is no way
that story's true
it's like why
would i make up
a 14-minute story
about a pop singer
that nobody's really heard of
and just as a side note i left out other
times that i ran into taylor day
anyway my name is tigg thanks so much
[Music]
oh thank you take notaro you guys have
been great i've been pete holmes good
night